we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's a caller confronting me about joe
biden
take a listen to this hi this is tom
from maine
i'm willing to bet money that you're not
going to answer this question
let's bet how much you want to bet i'm
going to answer it right now
do you think biden should take a mental
acuity test
why or why not all right so listen i
believe and have said before
we should uh i don't know
constitutionally
if it can even be done so i'm not saying
legally this is feasible
but my belief is it would be great
to do more screening and testing of
people who want to be
president so i would be if if we're
going to decide
every presidential candidate gets a
montreal cognitive assessment for
dementia that's fantastic do it
if we want to decide every president has
to
at least respond to basic
american history and constitution
questions maybe they're not barred from
running if they fail the test
but just so that we have the information
this is how this candidate did this
i'm fine doing a whole bunch of this
stuff okay i have no problem with that
whatsoever
what is absurd is that on the basis of
calling the montreal cognitive
assessment
um a mental acuity test when really it's
a it's a course
that's c-o-a-r-s-e it's a course
dementia screening
when trump lies about the difficulty
the point of the test the number of
questions
when bogus videos are used of joe biden
to justify joe biden needing to take it
or
because dr ronnie jackson says biden
should take it
none of those are reasons for biden to
take it i'm fine with biden
taking this test no problem if you want
to make it a requirement of every
candidate i'm completely with you
the story that the right has woven about
this test
is totally bogus about what the test
even is and what it does and everything
about it
and that's where i have a problem on the
bonus show today we'll talk about bill
cosby
we will talk about a four-day work week
we will talk about
a heat wave becoming a mass casualty
event it's insane what's going on
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by signing
up
at joinpakman.com one of our sponsors is
steadymd
primary care the easier and more
affordable way to do
primary care and they're giving you 50
off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed primary
care physician that's tailored to your
needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor
and from then on your doctor will be
available to you by text phone
and video chat it's not some random
doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50
off your first month when you go to
steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video